so when the night of the Oscars there
are all these parties in Hollywood but
only some of these parties are cool to
go that's right like I've always heard
the Vanity Fair party is the party to go
to and you told me in the past that you
have to get in him when you get invited
to the Vanity Fair party yeah there are
times that you're invited in other words
if you're an a-list actor you get
invited right at the beginning of the
party with a spouse or a plus-one yeah I
did say that yeah yeah and and and and
what happened this year where are you
now on the OCO but i will tell you this
year yes i stand ten o'clock with a
plus-one 10 o'clock you're allowed to go
in at 10 o'clock is that the most
happening around Michaels in there 10
o'clock centres because people that you
said there's like a midnight invite yeah
that you can't even get in till midnight
right and you don't even get to bring a
plus-one if you've had years where you
were midnight invite with no plus-one
think I died there's no way I would have
gone because I could even stay up that
late right the 10:00 p.m. invite is the
number one invite is that when the
parties I'm sure there's better actually
I saw Sarah Silverman and she goes what
were you and I go 10 she goes ooh
I go he/she goes 8 all I got so so I
don't even know if I'm allowed to talk
to you and she goes hey tens better she
was eight it's not even over yet I go
just come later soon as you can they're
over like 8:30 yeah and so then people
she goes 10 is good because everyone
shuffles out and they finally [ __ ]
rolling around 10 now what happens if
you show up early and you have a 10
o'clock invite do they tell you you
can't come you can't come in is that
true yep you've been told that yep what
yeah yeah turn you away [ __ ] yeah what
happened you go up and so I go there my
thing since 10 o'clock and my driver
goes no or not so I go you do what I
tell you Ron getting that goddamn line
and you bluffed and [ __ ] I don't
care what you say
right so I'm in the front you know and
then we pull up this guy's like hey mr.
Speight by the cops cops cops guys guys
I don't know why it's like so crazy
nanni he flashes the light on the front
he goes alright thanks wait whoa whoa
whoa
and it was like like slow motion he goes
goes to his lapel
we got a 10 o'clock customer service was
so Eagle Eagle so this woman comes over
the head honcho mm-hmm in trouble yeah I
was scared she really haven't asked them
no but she looked in and she goes how
dare you I got what it's not ten o'clock
so she goes David I'm so sorry it's 9:40
and you're at ten I go oh I didn't even
know there was times I told you 55 times
in Seneca I go you shut the [ __ ] up read
the script I gave you so he goes oh yeah
oh are there times and the lady goes
listen if it was up to me it is up to
you yeah who else is it up to if it was
up to me I'm like this is the most
embarrassing conversation I've ever
heard in history in history what is this
woman you're just stand up you got a TV
show you've been on Saturday Night Live
you've done movies the only I'm gonna do
I go what if I leave 20 minutes early
and she thinks about it mm-hmm don't you
guys know this guy's trying to [ __ ] me
she has now I'm not called that [ __ ]
yeah I just like want you run over to
Nate now let's grab a bagel
don't [ __ ] yourself I guess you should
go over to Nate no she's laughing she
goes you should have brought me like a
bottle of wine or whatever anyway she
was just do a lap she does come back at
9:50 I'll look the other way
Oh oh my I mean the rules for me oh my
god so I go are they do are they doing
this to ya wonder if they go just going
you know what I mean what if a 10:00
p.m. is dating an API